en
[Musique]
c'est une firme albertaine aux allures
plutôt au traditionnel mais entre les
vaches et la vieille camionnette se
cache pourtant un véritable laboratoire
dans ce petit conteneurs un biologiste
caresse grands projets le premier
élevage industriel d'insectes
comestibles en alberta l'appétit croix
pour les un certain soutien
entrepreneurs partout dans le monde des
investisseurs se tournent vers cette
source de protéines mais ceux qui on
mange ajoutent ils ont tendance à prony
l'achat le cas loïc par l'ofppt de
philosophy of animals
c'est précisément son créneau et ça
commence ici dans ces conditions à plus
de 30 degrés celsius et sous une
humidité tropicale ils y vivront d'amour
et d'eau fraîche et d'un peu de moules
et claudio les nourrit tous les deux ou
trois jours pendant cinq semaines le
temps qu'ils auraient vécu dans la
nature il femelles vont prendre beaucoup
d'eux jusqu'à 100 parcours
après quoi les insectes seront congelés
rôti puis moulu le résultat c'est cette
poudre 3 fois plus protéines et que la
viande de poulet aux subtiles notes de
noix de grenoble les grillons de claudio
doivent être sur le marché d'ici la fin
du mois notre élevage rappelle-t-il
génère une empreinte écologique beaucoup
moins importante que celle du bêta étant
dans l'espace que dans les ressources
nécessaires
c'est pour lui la nourriture du futur
oui des oiseaux
sous le vernis de vaud confiserie au
colorant rouge pétant en passant par la
soie de vos vêtements
les insectes vous suivent déjà peut-être
plus que vous ne l'imaginez vous les
mettrez vous bientôt sous la dent
claudio lesparre d'hyères ici simon
pierre poulin radio canada wide web en
alberta